[Music]
[Applause]
Dave Lapham has been working for the
Bengals radio network for over 30 years
former offensive tackle with the Bengals
good to have him back on the show take
me back to training camp Dave
what what was uh what was the Bengals I
guess uh personality like after losing
the Super Bowl
you know Dan it was interesting at
training camp because Joe borrow had had
the appendectomy so you know Joe was
healing I mean Joe couldn't go he wasn't
practicing
um the offensive lineman Collins had a
back problem Kappa had to he had a hip
flexor issue they had to have surgery on
they were beaten up and and so it's like
man got all these new offensive linemen
they can't they can't work they can't
practice together quarterbacks driving
around on a golf cart I mean our leader
is is uh disabled right now it was kind
of like what's going on you know
um but they still thought they had the
core of a damn good football team and
then Joe borrow healed up you know they
start off on two
um they go minus five Joe plays in the
opener and he was not himself
they go if I turn over five times you go
minus five and still could have won the
game missed an extra point missed a
field goal in overtime this next
reported the conclusion again in the
order won it I mean so it's like this
this is still a good football team since
then
13 out of 15 10 in a row I mean they
just got healthy everybody uh you know
realized hey if we do our part of what
111th of what we're supposed to do when
we're out there on the football field
we're pretty good and and they uh I
thought they played
from a timely standpoint their most
complete Game of the Year I thought that
they played a clean game they had no
turnovers they only had two penalties
two false starts for nine yards two
penalties for nine yards
um so they they played a clean game they
they played a complete game and they
played a complimentary football game the
three C's you can't beat the three C's
man what was the atmosphere like in
Buffalo
they were very confident the fan base
was extremely confident the bills were
very confident and uh
meteorologically the atmosphere was
funky
I mean it was it was uh it was chilly it
was it was pretty cold the wind chilled
in the 20s
um it was snowing big flakes at times
pretty good sized ones but the good
thing is Dan
no wind the wind was negligible and I
was surprised because I thought man you
got funky weather like that normally off
the lake here comes the wind you know
and and it was very very still the flags
were still the the uh the little banners
on top of the uh goal posts were you
know just flaccid just sitting there
they weren't moving so thought well they
can still throw the ball can still kick
it pretty well so and they and they just
went out and just they held with the
elements we're just gonna uh the thing
that they did Dan or that they wanted to
do that this football team now is 10 and
all when they score first they like to
land the first punch and they landed the
first punch and and they staggered the
Buffalo Bills they staggered Josh Allen
and the bills and then they they chased
them into the corner and just kept
throwing body shots you know they just
they they never let up on it so it was
like a heavyweight fight you hit the big
overhand right or the hook or whatever
you hit
stagger them and then just uh you know
TKO you know just just get after them
and and finish them and and that's uh
that's pretty much what they did all all
day long I mean they had an offensive
line Dan that had three new starters you
know I mean three weeks in a row they
lose the starting offensive lineman and
that group goes out and runs the ball
for over 170 yards on the defense it was
like number two in the NFL and rushing
yards allowed 170 yards and uh and as a
result Joe Barr only gets sacked one
time and gets hit two others Joe borrow
now in the last two seasons when he
sacked three times or less he's 23 wins
three losses protect protect Joe borrow
he's pretty good
have you figured him out personality
wise
he's that's a good question Dan he he is
uh I think he I think he works to make
it difficult to figure him out uh he's
he is a very very intelligent guy as a
very very broad uh base of Interest he's
he's not a uh he's not a one-trick pony
guy you know I mean he's he's got a lot
going on he is he is one sharp dude and
I'll tell you he is a football Savannah
I can tell you that this this guy is the
Albert Einstein of football man he's got
he's got the answers to the test and he
ain't cheating he knows it man and it's
he's got a confidence as a result of it
he's got an earned confidence that is
just you know borders on you know cocky
he's got the Swagger and boy his
teammates respond to him I mean it is
unbelievable he is definitely the duck
leading the ducklings I mean it's like
everybody else's little line behind the
big duck man and he's taking the
ducklings down to the pond fair to make
the comparison to Joe Montana
I think it is fair I think that's a good
comparison I really do I think that I
think they uh they're very similar I
think Joe might have a little bit
stronger on than Joe Montana but I think
he hit a great one because Joe Montana
had that kind of football mind he had
that kind of uh Charisma where his
teammates you know followed him followed
his lead and the big thing uh and Paul
Brown used to say this and it's so
simple but it's so true I remember you
know I was talking to him about
quarterback playing he goes David
a simple thing about quarterbacks is the
most important thing is the simplest
thing they got to throw it straight you
know I got to be accurate with the
football and man Joe borrow can put it
in the eye of a needle from 50 yards
away and that's what uh Joe Montana
could do Kenny Anderson all the great
quarterbacks that you know had that
accuracy pinpoint accuracy
always great to talk to you save that
voice for next weekend you're gonna need
it
I know it's going to be it's going to be
fun man they can't Dan have beaten the
Kansas City Chiefs three times in a
calendar year it could be a fourth in
less than 13 months if they can do it
again
are the Bengals in the chief's heads or
are the Chiefs going to be like that's
enough three in a row we gotta we gotta
stop this one it's gonna be it's gonna
be interesting out there good to talk to
you as always Dave thanks for joining us
thanks for the invitation you're the
best it's Dave Lapham he's been doing
the uh color commentating for the
Bengals radio network for over 30 years
he's right there he's a fan with a
microphone